we are at VL air force base up outside
of Sacramento California and we are
sitting in front of the YouTube the u2's
were developed in 1955 in order to
overfly the former Soviet Union and
other countries mostly Eastern Europe to
take photographic imagery to find out
their strengths and weaknesses if you
did not have the CIA clearance like
powers did there was you weren't allowed
to talk about it with your wife glutenin
powers he's just a pilot
it was making photographs from 70,000
feet when he was shot from this guy it
was not talked about the YouTube s model
which is behind us today was built in
the 1980s thing that really separates
the YouTube from other airplanes is the
altitude that we fly at we fly at
altitude of more than 70 thousand feet
through the nicknames of u2 is the
dragon lady when you're up in altitude
it's very smooth air up there it's very
easy to fly at times but then in a
moment's notice it acts like a dragon
and it can bite your head off one
landing might go very smooth and
uneventful and then the very next
landing really tests your ability
the chase car driver is actually another
YouTube pilot so they're really like
your wingman they actually talk you down
to the runway so they're giving you
altitude calls and helps you stall the
airplane at about two feet so that way
your tail will come down make contact
with the ground so it's vitally
important that you have that
relationship and Trust with the chase
car driver to get you on the ground
safely the u2 has a rich history over 60
years and the amount of attention that
went into really getting the story right
with the u2 I think they did a
tremendous job we're real appreciative
of it I was able to provide photographs
oral recordings of my father talking
about his experiences that Austin could
listen to to kind of get a feel for who
this man was when I was in that plane I
felt like powers I truly did when we
were here at BL Air Force Base being led
out to the u2 I was overwhelmed that day
because I truly was in the world and
this blue ray you know just allows
people to have the inside look at what I
was going through on a daily basis
it's a very large responsibility as an
actor to portray somebody like Mike
powers I hold him with as much regard as
I do
Washington or Roosevelt or any other
American figure that has been a hero and
he loved to fly
he loved to fly the u2 he thought it was
the best plane had ever been built it's
a childhood dream to be able to fly an
airplane like this and I feel really
fortunate that I get to do that on
almost a daily basis while yes I get to
be the guy that wears the funny
spacesuit and gets out into the airplane
being here at Beale Air Force Base
really lets you understand the big wool
and the thousands of people that go into
every single sortie it really is an
honor and it's humbling
you